hmm noisy hey everybody welcome to us
playing one two switch by Lucy in a
minute Tomales somewhere over there yeah
we're gonna play what we consider the
five weirdest games so the first one I'm
not sure how familiar you could be with
this but it's called shave shave shave
it's a game I'm shaving your beard which
you might think I'll have an advantage
with I don't shave a beard so yeah you
must yeah trim it but I don't go ham
okay well I mean we're watching the
video now this post you guys have got
you know proficiency with shaving the
guy it's electric shavers go it's the
first person to shave all that stubble
of is the winner
you ready l we need to do the eye
contact thing chin like I began my
physical hair stuck in the thing go
practice it's fine this is like like
teaching you sir to shave the first time
teaching my son how to shave Hey it's
uncomfortable that it makes you like
look at you in the eyes yeah it's like
it's a warped mirror of myself when I'm
in the actual mirror shaving - what are
you saying about massage haha you shave
your face muffin lady huh what yes are
you waiting hundred percent I have
actual facial hair so do i what oh my
god I'm sorry just look at the scale
look at this go get the little bit and
then well you win the shave it was a
close shave
next minigame you think that you may be
more evenly matched than Lucy and I
because you've both got bids don't put
up your nose don't put up your nose
my droidcon is ugly it's not even going
anywhere near put of your nose how do
you rethink this you know you're just
gonna probably okay look it's not moving
still moving look at the officious
motions I like that actually vibrates
misspent your hair ah they're like the
infrared thing he was catching my hair I
don't why I'm like keeping my skin taut
like a dog shave we should did you see I
was trying to leave how am I so bad at
shape may I shaved my face my whole face
every part of this face close shave look
at this you just shaved up your own eye
you're blind now this is called soda
shake if you imagine this is a disaster
drink doctor thunder yes miss your peb
el sheikh yeah you got to pass it and
shake it pass it around the person who
pops the ball uses me excuse me
no I mean I first hold on nothing just
shake it shake that soda oh this is
gonna be so hard
look at the hello again another Super
Bowl you don't have to keep shaking eat
faster oh geez do you know very well
every time she orders of the coke it's
just a nightmare the more vibrates the
zestier it's gone no you need it for
safety this is making me uncomfortable
hot potato up there
don't be weird
watch the dough my guards because you're
really good at it
oh wow it's probably familiar she
familiar scene for Dave there this is a
children's game and so does hello all
ages ready
it's few flavors of soda careful
what's the soda shaker I pay extreme
pure this sorry shaker shake you copy
no you have to show you oh it doesn't go
scrub three-time bruise no actually
extends classic time Oh Millia seen
pattern shows everybody it's a bad day
freak it up
drink you out okay this is milk you
might have seen this already it's quite
a popular one familiar scenes here for
time I've worked on a phone you have no
way to verify this I lived in texts on
for many years I'll ask your brother I
did you milk making noises very warm
look at your hands
this is my hands again this way I got me
this weird Mei
all right I want a rematch
Rabia project rub for the prettiest No
yes there was a game called pretty Romeo
me
is this the banner of the game by the
hand are you licking your lips this milk
isn't for drinking it's not pasteurized
let you go faster don't hurt the cow
leather Oh lift up that way spray it a
bit of a sensual experience doesn't it
name does it remind you like give me a
massage or something lips with cow king
whose campaign stops it my cousin split
sit down son your boy got ten cups here
you go nine okay but tank up David Corey
this is so this is my child your child
ugly as hell girl this child is white
it's not my child what I mean treat me
I'm not
maternal paternal so I've got a quite
hairy child it also has to be upside
down because Chewbacca's face like means
that the joy carnal form of so I have to
hold the baby
Wilfred all right Chewie let's do this I
hold the baby I'm holding the baby okay
it's calibrating there we go okay
Thanks
I'm gonna be the best dad is about to be
dead if you don't shop my strategy is
the one on keeping the debt collectors
away there isn't a minute diaper get out
of here you'll never know how to get
nice thief in about six months keep them
here for hours you dropped your baby
it's not my phone this chair is slotted
this is not fair my head
he's dead I am a bad parent babies
definitely their best dad
boom a four set down give up so this
one's guerrilla tryna get in a rainbow
so you got to match the rhythm with this
motion don't hit me in the face
actually you're gonna hit me that's my
natural ninja instincts chicken ice I
should be kind of self-explanatory but
this game is about I think it's about
having sex in a bush between two
gorillas it was like cooler in the back
isn't waiting oh my god is this we're
the two male gorillas fight together
yeah we're the two trying to be alpha
faster than both hands so both that
counts don't actually have to punch your
own chest I mean I'm pretty sure that's
not what Nintendo is intending intend oh
[Music]
okay you really don't have any other D
there you go fine whatever
all right we're gonna listen to the
thing that noise listen you listen
okay okay say the other one another
oh you're gonna get a look from the bush
god this is gonna be it
you gotta love that's sweet goodness
[Music]
you ain't got no girl I love girl yeah
get that Bush over here yes look at me
look at me
defeated on the fumble Malcolm I appeal
you get it
I don't have rhythm its appeal you gonna
have it go up on the bush saying the
first time I fought for the love of a
gorilla try making some good will do it
yeah
we both got equal amounts of love not
hate yourself
I'd like to tell that to a gorilla can
you not hit you just please okay give it
to me anyway
don't give me that gorilla love now you
hussy
yes yeah back onto gorilla tinder right
well thanks for watching us play the
Nintendo switch if you enjoyed make sure
hit that like button if you wanna see
more switch stuff then make sure to
subscribe to GameSpot we are we
definitely look forward to reading your
comments on this one find us on Twitter
ah sorry shaker that's not wide turn I'm
at too much I'm at it and I met Lucy
James gates don't forget to subscribe
the games walk and we'll see you